maybe wearable I've told people to
members the board not to watch it I hope
they did someone will tell them to watch
it but I would be concerned
I remember this board and a minimum and
I have to investigate everything that we
just identified and if it's the
slightest bit true you know so a lot of
legal work to do here and I hope the
board has good independent
representation the companies
representing that these sales and
nutrition clubs are sort of you know
these were like they call it we're
competing against McDonald's so they say
that's what DeSimone says we do our
competition as McDonald's as far as I
can tell McDonald's doesn't run its
business this way forty to fifty percent
of the revenue to the company come from
a visit business method called a
Nutrition Club which itself is entirely
fraudulent they've got fake customers
these are not customers these are people
who are buying into a mini pyramid
scheme alright
there's nothing circumstantial about it
we have facts Carl Icahn is one of the
great back-of-the-envelope investors of
all time he's made 22 billion dollars on
the back of an envelope a Carl Icahn
didn't do the kind of due diligence we
did but the nutrition club thing is
designed to be secretive okay this is
you know what ingenious fraud we had
investigators go in and become part of
the program and we took a record of
those meetings we enrolled in training
programs and we had and we observed all
of the laws in doing so with the
assistance of our counsel